good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe and I believe that
you have something special that when you
unleash it it will be able to change the
world so to help you on your journey
today's message is actively practice
gratitude
over to you brené Brown what I found you
know 12 years of research 11,000 pieces
of data I had I did not interview and
all that time a person who would
describe themselves as joyful or
describe their lives as joyous who did
not actively practice gratitude and for
me it was very counterintuitive because
I kind of went into the research
thinking that the relationship between
joy and gratitude was if you're joyful
then you should be grateful but it
wasn't that way at all it was really
that practicing gratitude invites Julian
turn our lives and when I say practice I
think this is this is the part that
really changed my life it changed my
family and the way we live every day
when I say practice gratitude I don't
mean kind of like the attitude of
gratitude or feeling grateful
I mean practicing gratitude these folks
shared in common a tangible gratitude
practice they either kept gratitude
journals some of them did interesting
things like at 1 2 3 4 like at 12:30 for
every day they said something out loud
that they were grateful for they one of
the things that we do like we say grace
at dinner and so now after grace we go
around and everyone in my family says
something they're grateful for I mean
including what's interesting is when we
first started I have a first grader at
first grade son Charlie and 8th grade
daughter Ellen and at first I thought
and we've been doing for a couple years
now like they're like oh god mom and if
there was a little like this is you know
are you experimenting on us it was a
little bit of that but now what's
interesting even after we did it for
like a couple of weeks that on those
crazy busy nights where we're trying to
like get to soccer and piano and
homework and Steve and I are just like
resuit we say a quick prayer we start
eating like
like whoa what are you grateful for and
it's been extraordinary because not only
absolutely does it invite more joy into
our house it also is such a soulful
window into what's going on in my kids
lives you know so there's some days
where my eighth grader I'll be like I'm
joyful that there's a huge thick wall
between my room and my brother's room
you know something he's very you know
honest but there other day she'll say
you know she had a friend whose mother
recently died and she said you know for
a month she would say I'm just so
grateful that y'all are healthy right
now you know and so not only did it make
us all more aware of what we had and
more willing to slow down and really be
thankful for the joyful moments we had
but it let me know where she was
emotionally in her life you know my side
is always yeah I'm grateful for bugs I'm
grateful for frogs but sometimes he'll
say you know I'm grateful that you
picked me up early or you know I'm
grateful that I finally understand
adjectives you know so it's there's a
great quote that says it's not granted
it's not joy that makes us grateful it's
gratitude that makes us joyful and it's
by a Jesuit brother a Jesuit priest and
I guess I was just amazed to find that
bubble up so strongly in the research
it's life changing so I've had a
gratitude practice for the past couple
of years it started off when I heard I
think it was Tony Robbins say that you
can't have gratitude and anger in
yourself at the same time like if you
are really grateful for something then
you can't be angry and frustrated at the
same time and so it's a great medicine
if you're ever feeling angry frustrated
upset then just shifting the perspective
to just being grateful asking yourself
what can be grateful for and if you can
actually feel it it takes away the anger
and the pain and the suffering and the
frustration so I thought it was an
interesting task and I just started by
writing three things down every night I
had this little stack of paper those
like Tarot ways and I write three things
down every night that I was grateful for
general I'm optimistic happy person you
may think well why do you need that but
I think there's always room to try to
get better to try to be happier to try
to feel more fulfilled to look for other
hacks and tests and whenever somebody
throws a new thing at me like hey you
should try this okay let's give it a
shot let's see how it works see if it
benefits me or not and so it was
something that I kept up doing is
something that I found some benefit in
doing mostly just because of the
perspective shift just of one when I'm
frustrated or angry I can try to think
about you know what am i grateful for
but to just iya would always try to find
something of my three things that was a
little different so there's the common
things that I'm grateful for this great
country that I mean I'm grateful for my
wife from giving for my son I'm grateful
for my dog Kimo and his crazy energy but
then I would also always try to find
something that I would normally not
really notice you know I'm grateful for
this table
I'm grateful that is a really good
height for me I'm grateful that I can
have my books on here I'm grateful that
it looks modern and nicer I'm grateful
for that tree outside and just think of
things that normally would go on notice
and finding a way to be grateful for it
I found just really shifted my
perspective a lot so I've been doing
that for a couple years and I found it
really helpful for me I would encourage
you to at least give it a shot and see
if it works for you the extra step that
I took that maybe is interesting for you
guys who are running a team or have a
group of people is I created a Facebook
group where I've invited the people who
are on my team who want to join in and
share and every weekday we post three
things that were grateful for and one
thing that we have learned today and so
it's a daily habit for the people on my
team myself and them where we're sharing
three things and again I always try to
find one thing that's a little different
little you know like the table or or the
tree outside just a little perspective
change but then also it's a great way to
be able to get to know the other people
on my team better and what they're up to
because when you're having meetings
you're talking about business and work
and you might ask them about their life
and what's going on and you learn about
important issues but people are posting
pictures of the camping trip that they
took or the food that they ate and
sharing things that you wouldn't
normally ask in a conversation and so
it's a great way to build your team cam
stream for people to get to know each
other as well so that was a little
modification that I found super helpful
and then just one last thought just
around the perspective shift was I used
to get really upset in traffic and
waiting for the elevator those two
things always really kind of drove me
nuts because I don't like wasting time
wasting time is among my biggest pet
peeves and if I'm wasting my talent
something I'm look I look for something
else to do immediately but when you're
stuck in traffic you're waiting for an
elevator is not really a ton of options
and so shifting the expectation to
gratitude so I'm expecting this I'm
expecting to get here quickly it's not
happening and so you get frustrated
shift on that expectation to one of
gratitude and just saying what kind of
be grateful for and so for the elevator
I'm frustrated like where's the elevator
somebody's moving in until like there's
one less elevator and I'm sitting there
you're maybe with groceries and I want
to get up and I just think you know what
there's this magical box that takes me
from the basement floor up to the 13th
floor where I have tons of groceries in
my hand that I don't have to walk the
stairs like these didn't exist you know
a while ago and just that perspective
ship allows me to be grateful for the
elevator and same thing for a car like
I'm stuck in traffic I'm trying to get
somewhere you know we didn't have cars
before we couldn't travel those kinds of
distances before I'd have a much limited
life if I didn't have the ability to get
in the car and drive somewhere and it
just if I can remember and sometimes I
need someone around me to to help shift
it I try to tell me Malik Nina okay if
you see me frustrated you know just
remind me remind me to be grateful
thinking about it having that
perspective shift immediately takes away
the frustration the anger the resentment
the expectations and moves me to much
happier calm grateful place and so it
encourage you guys to try it out test it
as your own morning routine or even
routine if it works for you you've
encouraged your team members to come in
as well or friends it can be a great way
to kind of get to know each other better
and keep that motivation going on the
other basis and might just make a huge
impact on your life worth a shot at
least so the question of the day today
is I'm curious do you have a gratitude
practice is this something that you've
been doing for
while or is something that you are
willing to test out for the next 10 days
and see if it has an impact on you or
not I'd love to hear from you please
share your thoughts and experiences down
in the comment section below I also want
to give a quick shout out to yo-yo Cruz
yo-yo thank you so much for picking up a
copy of my book your one word I hope you
enjoy the read and I really appreciate
your support so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love and
I'll see you guys again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso
[Music]
the next phase here is also to become
grateful for what it is that you do have
so if you're starting to try to create
change in your life you want to make
sure that you're really focusing on what
it is that you do have in your life so
that you feel an energy of gratitude and
an energy of gratitude can really open
you up to this incredible capacity to
feel more energized to feel more happy
in any given moment where you feel like
oh I don't have what I need or I'm not
supported or things aren't working out
the simple step here is to just say I am
grateful for what I do have and let me
look at me say I'm grateful for what I
do have we create more of what we want
and the energy of gratitude opens our
heart and it expands our energy and it
makes us a much more wonderful loving
person to be around and with that loving
energy we begin to attract more into our
life and so we want to really make sure
that that energy of gratitude is a very
pinnacle part of this group this miracle
worker process which is that we stay
committed and open to what it is that we
are here to receive and we stay
committed and grateful for what it is
that we have and so you can begin today
just by making a gratitude list and
focus on it in there's so many moments
when I think oh my god I can't believe I
have to do this or I can't believe I've
to get to that and and then I just think
about what I'm grateful for and it just
spins me immediately out of the crazy
chaos and back into a central place of
love and so I think that this is a
really valuable tool for you to begin to
use regularly and it's an active tool
throughout the book make us miracles if
you're obsessed you know what you want
you take a massive action maybe you
modeled somebody figure out the right
action so you get there quicker then
you're executing you still need a little
grace some people call it luck you could
call god but I really believe that
there's the part we do and then there's
the part that comes to us but I do know
grace shows up a lot more when you do
the first two steps on your own and
grace shows up a lot more when you
acknowledge grace in your life when you
acknowledge that I was born in a world
where I didn't have to build this
internet that I can pull out of my
pocket the answer anything on earth I am
driving on streets
I didn't pave I'm reading
I didn't have to write that's the gift
of our lives and I think when we
experience that grace we don't just
experienced more achievement but we
start to experience more fulfillment and
grace not only affects your ability to
get there but it affects what you do and
how you lean you live once you are there
it really determines the quality of your
life because unless you live in a state
of gratitude you know I did an interview
with Sir John Templeton who as you know
is one of the first billionaire
investors and just a brilliant man he
came from nothing and he don't eat any
was seven and fifteen they still do it
the Templeton fund I think it's seven
and fifty million dollars a year it's
bigger than a Nobel fund that he donates
and one day asked him I said what is the
secret to wealth he looked to me pause
this big smile his eyes got really
bright like they always did and he said
Tony it's what you teach I said well I
teach a lot of things you know it's
thing he said gratitude he said because
you night oneno billionaires that are
miserable and it's because they're not
grateful for what they have and we both
know people have no money seemingly but
they're so grateful for their health for
their husband for their life for their
children they're so grateful to God
they're so grateful for their life that
they're rich you know so I think I think
it starts with that gratitude it starts
with that connection to grace is
simplistic as that sounds and so it's
not enough just to have your financial
plan you have all the money and be
miserable
what's of the money and be really rich
emotionally psychologically it's finally
waking up every morning and figuring out
even in a difficult situation where the
pieces of gratitude are so like coming
into the city yesterday or the day
before I was stuck in traffic and I was
late for something and I was like oh you
got to go faster but this is an
opportunity for a difficult to solve a
difficult gratitude problem which is
it's the city I'm going to is so amazing
and wonderful that everyone else wants
to be here even faster than me